it's time again for another update video
this one is about all the things we've
got coming up in April and all the
things that took place in March as usual
I'm a little bit behind in getting this
produced and posted but I think when I
talk about all the things that went on
in March you'll understand why that's
the case now before i talk about march i
want to put three things out there as
sort of highlights that I'd really like
to call your attention to because
they're things I'm very proud of the
first one is that I've actually started
a patreon page and campaign for the half
hour hagel series if you've been
following my work you know that over the
last year I have been producing videos
running through Hegel's phenomenology
one paragraph at a time and its
projected to last a number of years down
the line it's going to take me a long
time to realize this a lot of work so I
I offered patrons the opportunity to to
back the project if you don't know about
it if you're interested in this sort of
thing i'll put links to it here and you
can you can find out about it another
thing is that I've got my philosophical
foundations class with the global Center
for Advanced Studies it's an online
eight week class you know going into the
very foundations of philosophy for for
beginners essentially but intermediate
students could also benefit from it that
is starting this week and enrollment
will continue into next week as well up
to the 16th of of April so if you're
interested in that you can take it for
credit you can audit it at a much
reduced rate it's going to be a really
great experience for all the students
that are that are involved so I'm very
excited about that and the third thing
is I had an article published in the
Oxford philosopher a piece on the five
states of nature and Hobbes Leviathan so
if you're saying yourself wait a second
dr. Sandler I think there's only one
state of nature there give the article
read see what you think let's talk now
about March March was an extraordinarily
busy month I know that I've used that
phrase several times in
videos previous to this one but man it
really was so one of the things that I
did that I'm really happy about I've
been talking about getting a website up
and running for a reason I owe the
company through which I do this and all
the speaking engagements and a lot of
the other things that that my partner
and I are involved in I finally got the
website up and running it's not
completely built out but at least you
can get some idea about our professional
presence so it's a good place to go to
as well for the blog because you'll see
me posting announcements in there about
talks about upcoming opportunities about
classes all sorts of things like that
talks I gave two and a half talks over
the course of the last month I say two
and a half because one of them was given
in absentia so I'll tell you more about
that in a minute the two talks that I
actually gave face to face in person
were both at the kingston library both
were parts of a series that we've got
going with them with their hosting
community discussions community lectures
one of them is in the understanding
anger series and this time we focused on
Plato who doesn't yet have a systematic
theory of anger he's getting there and
Aristotle's going to take us there but
it does have a lot of really interesting
stuff to say from a philosophical
perspective so you can see the video of
that talk available we also did another
reconsidering community discussion this
time it was reconsidering Charlie Hebdo
see were talking about free speech and
about the you know the incident itself
about the outpouring of support and what
it meant about the notion of giving
offense and about violence and I focused
in my portion of the talk on the
relationship between free speech and an
offense and how we ought to think about
that now I also gave a paper in absentia
my friend Christopher annandale was kind
enough to read the paper for me and even
a field questions apparently I couldn't
be there because the the Cicero nian
society conference
taking place down in Maryland at the
same time as I was giving the plato
talked up here in Kingston so I gave a
paper to Chris about Aristotle's theory
of anger and and about how it provides
us some really useful ideas and
approaches that are that are often
missing in contemporary discussions of
anger so he took it and he read it and
I'm going to be expanding that paper and
submitting it to their journal Ottoman
ases so you may see that coming out
later this year what else a lot of stuff
going on with the global Center for
Advanced Studies I have two things in
particular that I want to bring up it's
been taking a lot of my time and I think
after I tell you you'll understand quite
quite why that's the case so one of them
is I've been building an online class
and if you've ever taken a class with me
you know that I put a lot more into
classes than most instructors do I
provide a lot of resources I build
lesson pages I shoot videos like this
everything is very structured students
know what they're getting into I even
continue while I'm teaching the course
is to develop stuff as additional
resources so I've been building that
philosophical foundations class that is
starting very very soon we've already
got you know quite a few students
enrolled but we've got plenty of room
for more so if you're interested in the
class it's going to be a great
experience you get to take a class with
me see me and interact with me for two
hours a week by videoconference I'll
have all sorts of other cool resources
available for you and I'll give you
feedback on papers the other big news is
and this has been something that's been
building for for a bit but we had to
remain fairly quiet about it is I've
been appointed to a director's position
in the Institute of critical philosophy
with the global Center for Advanced
Studies and the reason why they asked me
with that is because it's a fairly new
institution and I have some experience
in
you know academic leadership in
assessment and accreditation in you know
all these sorts of things plus I'm a
committed teacher plus I I'm you know in
agreement with gks is basic principles
and their their manifesto and what they
want to do with it so it's a really
exciting opportunity I get to work with
world-class faculty members and help
build a new program in philosophy I'm
very honored to be part of it and it's
also an awful lot of work so that's
that's where a lot of my time and effort
has been going at the same time I've
been continuing to teach my class my
online class from Maris world views and
values I have been teaching the player
no class existentialist philosophy and
literature that I developed for for them
and what else I started like I pointed
out the half hour Hagel Patrian page
where if you want to you can actually
sign up to support my work in a very
tangible way people commit a certain
amount of money per video you can
actually set limits so if you commit
like you know one dollar per video but
you only want to commit to do that you
know once a month or four times a month
so that there'd be a cap on it you can
do that and I've got you know right now
not too many people because I didn't I
didn't publicize it that much but I
created a video for it which there's a
link to below and if you think that this
sort of thing is valuable I highly
encourage you to become a patron of the
project there's there's a couple reasons
why one is of course you know it'll help
me make a living shooting these videos
each one hour or half hour installment
takes me anywhere from four to five
hours to produce so that's quite a bit
of my time and I'm sharing these with
the world for free as a educational
resource that's one-of-a-kind it's
really nobody else is doing this sort of
thing at least not with Hagel and it's
going to be out there for years and
perhaps decades or generations to come
so you can be part of something that
that's quite big the other thing is I
give you benefits if you do it you know
you get to be part of
the Patrian feed I'll actually send you
a handwritten thank you note if you
pledge enough i'll send you a copy of
the phenomenology with an inscription by
me and I don't just mean a signature I
mean I'll actually write something
there's participation in the monthly Q&A
sessions at a certain level you actually
start getting free tutorial sessions
from me but you can see all about that
on the site if you're interested videos
so I shot two half-hour Hagel videos
this month I didn't get to shoot as many
as i would have liked but you know
that's going to change in the future i
did get the critical thinking fallacy
videos back up and running and so i'm
really happy about that I also you know
produce some videos of the talks that I
gave and I released a number of the
world views and values videos I think I
was finishing up with Descartes and I
released a lot of Rousseau ones and I
started releasing the Mary
Wollstonecraft videos during march i
also did some blogging and some academic
writing never as much as i would have
liked but you know that's that's me
because I'm kind of a over achiever I
did some philosophical counseling and I
did quite a bit of tutoring you know and
if you're interested in that sort of
stuff you can you can go to the reason I
owe website and you can see about it not
the philosophical counseling quite yet
but but pretty soon that takes us
through March let's talk now about April
so I've got to tocs coming up one is a
talk on Aristotle and anger it's part of
that understanding anger series so if
you're in the kingston area if you're in
the the greater hudson valley area and
you've got an inkling to come by on a
saturday it's this saturday the eleventh
1030am to about 12 p.m. although they
usually run a bit longer and you guys
know i've been researching aristotle and
anger now about close to eight years I'm
writing a book on Aristotle and anger so
this this one is going to probably be
the best out of all of these
understanding anger
lectures that I'm giving I've got
another talk at the unit the Unitarian
Universalist community of the Catskills
it's a fundraising lecture for them and
I'm going to be talking about humility
and whether it is a vice or a virtue and
we're going to look at five or six
different philosophical figures ranging
from Aristotle to Nietzsche including
st. Anselm and Mary Wollstonecraft's a
about about humility that is on the 21st
which is a tuesday evening at 7pm i
start the global Center for Advanced
Studies class on on the 9th which is
just a few days from now and enrollment
will close on the 14th so if you're
interested in taking a class with me
this is an opportunity to do so this
class by the way is going to be part of
the core curriculum for the g KS 0 g KS
fairly soon is going to be offering a
certificate in critical philosophy and
that's going to be one of the classes
that that'll be at the core of that i'm
finishing up teaching my player know
existentialism class and i'm going to be
you know looking at that and turning it
around and creating a new section of
that that'll that'll be starting
sometime in June continuing teaching my
Maris world views and values class still
going to build out the reason I owe
website some more and i'm reworking the
blogs that I've got out there to make
them a little bit more aesthetically
pleasing a little bit easier on the eyes
perhaps even a little bit better
organized there's a lot of little work
to do with them so videos I've got my
plan for this month is at least for half
hour hagel videos in the section
perception which we started last month
I'm going to do a lot more critical
thinking fallacy videos I don't think
we'll finish up the fallacies this month
but we might get you know some real
headway made I'll do videos of my talks
so if you can't be there you can at
least see them and comment
them world views and values I'm still
releasing more of those those videos
that I shot originally for my mayor of
students and now I'm making available to
you we've got some more Wollstonecraft's
it is she's a thinker I particularly
like and then after we're done with Mary
Wollstonecraft we're gonna do some marks
actually marks and angles but but mostly
marks and hopefully we'll get all of
those out this month I'm going to be
doing more blogging and more academic
writing I'm doing more tutoring I was
doing tutoring through google helpouts
but Google helpouts is they decided to
phase it out there's a whole long story
there that we don't need to go into but
you know you can google it and he'll
find out what Google did long story
short if you want to book me for
tutoring sessions you now do that
through the reason I owe website it's
it's a you know available there the
information or you can email me at Greg
at reason I oh and ask me and i'll send
you a fee sheet if you're interested I
also will be doing philosophical
counseling I have room for more clients
if you've got philosophical ideas
existential crises that sort of thing
that you want to work your way through
with a trained practitioner you can you
can do that with me for that you'd want
to email me at Greg at reason I oh I
don't have that part of the site built
out yet but I will hopefully by the end
of this week the last thing that I'm
going to say is I've started using I
started using what you could call
newsletters for lack of a better word to
try to reach out to some of my local
followers and subscribers and people
that are interested in what I'm doing
I've been doing that just for local
things but I'm going to be broadening
the newsletters now so that if you want
to stay updated on different things that
are going on through reason I oh through
the talks that I give through the
classes that I
teach any of that sort of stuff you can
actually subscribe to the newsletters
and I'm going to offer a link that will
allow you to do that in the description
of this video also be posting that on
facebook and google+ and in other places
as well but if you want to stay updated
and you don't want to wait around just
you know once a month for these videos
to come out that would be the way to do
it so long story short a lot that
happened in March a lot on the plate for
April and we're already one week into
April but fortunately April has has a
lot of days in it the three things i had
mentioned at the beginning half hour
hagel Patrian the philosophical
foundations class and the hobbs article
those are the things that I'd
particularly like to call your attention
to I hope you have a good month because
I'm already having one